Bu Efe, 6. sınıfa gidiyor ve okula her sabah yürüyerek gider.
O sabah, köşedeki kaldırım rampasının önünde bir araba duruyordu.
Efe, arabanın etrafından dolandı ve yoluna devam etti.
Arkasından gelen sınıf arkadaşı derinse dolanamadı.
Derin tekerlekli sandalyesiyle rampanın önünde durmak zorunda kaldı.
Efe, o sabah her gün yanından geçtiği bir şeyi ilk kez gördü.
İnsanlar yaşamlarını toplum içinde, orta kalanları paylaşarak sürdürür.
Bu ortak yaşamda kirlilik, trafik ve erişim sorunlarıyla karşılaşılabilir.
Birçok insanı aynı anda etkileyen bu durumlara toplumsal sorun denir.
Bireysel sorun, yalnız belirli kişileri etkiler.
Bozulan bir oyuncak gibi.
Toplumsal sorunsa, toplumun geniş bir bölümünü ilgilendirir.
Efe, o hafta mahallesine ilk kez dikkatle baktı.
Kaldırım rampasının önünde her sabah başka bir araba duruyordu.
Köşedeki çöp kutusu taşmış, poşetler kaldırıma yayılmıştı.
Sokak lambaları güpegündüz yanmaya devam ediyordu.
Okulun karşısındaki yolda güvenli bir yaya geçidi yoktu.
Bir sorunu çözmek, önce onu doğru fark etmekle başlar.
Efe bir hafta boyunca defterine gözlemlerini yazdı.
Komşulara sordu, muhtarlıktan bilgi aldı.
Trafiğin tek bir nedeni olmadığını gördü.
Herkes kendi arabasıyla ve çoğu zaman tek başına gidiyordu.
Toplu taşıma yetersizdi, hatalı park edense çoktu.
Bir sorunun nedenleriyle sonuçları birbirine bağlıdır.
Egzoz gazları ve pusil yakıtlar havayı kirletir.
Kirli hava insan sağlığını ve doğal yaşamı olumsuz etkiler.
Efe kirli bir günde okul bahçesinden ufka baktı.
Her gün gördüğü karşı tepe, o gün görünmüyordu.
Toplumsal sorunlar herkesi aynı ölçüde etkilemez.
Çocuklar, yaşlılar ve özel gereksinimli bireyler daha çok etkilenir.
Efe kaldırımı bir kez de derinin yüksekliğinden gördü.
Bebek arabası süren bir anne aynı yerde durmak zorunda kaldı.
Bastonuyla yürüyen yaşlı bir adam yolun ortasından dolaştı.
Çözüm üretilirken farklı ihtiyaçlar dikkate alınmalıdır.
Efe ve arkadaşları sınıfta çözüm önerilerini yazdı.
Bir çözüm önerisi sorunun nedenine yönelik olmalıdır, uygulanabilir ve toplum yararına olmalıdır.
İnsanların haklarını gözetmeli ve kalıcı sonuç üretmelidir.
Rampanın önüne yaya önceliğini gösteren bir işaret istediler.
Köşeye ayrıştırmalı geri dönüşüm kutuları konulmasını önerdiler.
Çözümde kurumlar ve vatandaşlar farklı sorumluluklar üstlenir.
Belediye ekipleri kutuları yerleştirdi ve köşeyi temizledi.
Bir sivir toplum kuruluşu okulda bildilendirme çalışması yaptı.
Mahalle sakinleri atıklarını ayırarak kutulara atmaya başladı.
Bireyler sorunlara duyarlı olmalı ve çözüme katılmalıdır.
Efe ve arkadaşları bir dilekçe yazdı.
Dilekçeyi okul müdürüne ve muhtarlığa ulaştırdılar.
Bozuk sokak lambasını ilgili birime bildirdiler.
Gönüllü olarak çevre temizliği çalışmasına katıldılar.
Uygulanan çözüm sonuçlarına bakılarak değerlendirilir.
Bir ay sonra toplanan atık miktarı belirgin biçimde azalmıştı.
Sorun sürüyorsa plan yeniden gözden geçirilir ve geliştirilir.
Bir sabah Efe yine aynı köşeye geldi.
Rampanın önü boştu ve derin yukarı tek başına çıktı.
Toplumsal sorunların çözümü onları fark etmekle başlar.
Sorunları fark eder, çözümleri birlikte üretiriz.
Peki sen çevrende hangi toplumsal sorunu fark ettin?
Cevaplarınızı yorumlara bekliyoruz. Meraklı kalın. Çözüm üretmeye devam edin.